A lot of people have been waiting for
this video for a long time,
so let's get right into it.
Let's talk about geeks.
I am a geek.
I'm a language Geek,
but these days I'm also a video making
geek.
Perhaps the most famous geeks in the
world are Otaku people who are obsessed
with Japanese animation and comic book
culture.
Our Mickey,
what do you want?
Sorry,
Mickey.
I don't understand what you're saying,
so hold on a second.
Oh,
right.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Greek language or
as it's called in Greek.
The word Greek is a word that instantly
brings to mind images of ancient
civilizations and culture.
It may not be the most widely spoken
language in the world today,
but it did play an extremely influential
role in the development of other
European languages and in European
culture in general.
Today,
it's spoken by more than 13 million
native speakers,
mainly in Greece where it's the only
official language and a spoken by 11
million people.
The Republic of Cyprus where it's spoken
by around 975,000
people and by minorities and parts of
Albania,
Italy and Turkey,
as well as by Greek immigrants living
all around the world.
Whether you realize it or not,
if you know English,
you know some Greek,
around 6% of the vocabulary of English
is of Greek origin,
and some estimates reach as high as 12
to 15% and if we look specifically at
the sciences and technology,
the proportion of Greek words and roots
skyrockets dramatically.
When you mentioned the encyclopedia,
or when you talk about physics class or
when you ask for the butter,
you're using words that developed from
Greek history,
Greek as a member of the Hellenic branch
of the Indo European language family.
Some consider Hellenic to be a single
language branch consisting of only
Greek,
while others consider some varieties of
modern Greek to be closely related but
separate languages.
The development of Greek can be broken
down into a number of stages.
Prodo Greek protocol,
Greek or protocol,
Hellenic developed from Prodo Indo
European and was probably spoken in the
third millennium bce.
Over 4,000
years ago as Hellenic people migrated
into the Belkin peninsula,
or maybe even earlier,
depending on where and when.
Prodo Indo European originated Mycenaean
Greek Mycenaean Greek is the form of
Greek that developed in Mycenaean Greece
in the second millennium bce when the
Greek mainland first advanced
civilization arose.
The earliest known Greek text comes from
this period dating back to around 1400
bce.
It's a clay tablet written in a writing
system called linear b,
not the system that we know today as the
Greek alphabet.
The existence of such tablets makes
Greek,
the oldest recorded living language.
To be clear,
there are older texts written in other
languages like Sumerian,
Egyptian hieroglyphics,
and the KTN,
but those are all dead languages.
While Greek has lived on until today,
sometime toward the end of the Mycenaean
Greek stage or in the early part of the
ancient Greek stage,
the Greek alphabet was adopted.
The date of adoption is around 1100 bce
plus or minus a couple of hundred years.
We're not quite sure.
The Greek alphabet was derived from the
Phoenician alphabet with Greek adopting
and modifying the finish and letters,
and generally keeping similar sounds for
each one.
There are also several unique Greek
letters that did not derive from
Phoenician.
You may notice that some of the symbols
are reversed that might be explained by
the fact that physician was written from
right to left while Greek is written
from left to right.
At first,
there were numerous local varieties of
the Greek alphabet,
but the standard 24 letter Greek
alphabet became widespread throughout
the Greek speaking world.
During the fourth century bce in Cyprus,
a different script called the Cypriots.
Syllabary was used between the 11th and
fourth centuries bce when the Greek
alphabet was finally adopted,
the Greek alphabet.
What eventually give rise to numerous
other alphabets,
including the Latin Alphabet,
the Coptic Alphabet,
but the Cyrillic alphabet and the Gothic
alphabet ancient Greek.
The adoption of the Greek alphabet took
place around the beginning of the
ancient Greek stage of the language,
which lasted from about the ninth
century bce until the fourth century
bce.
This stage of the language corresponds
to the archaic and classical periods of
Greek history,
the oldest existing Greek literature and
indeed some of the oldest western
literature dates from this period,
including the two epic poems,
the Iliad and the Odyssey,
which are attributed to homer.
There were various dialects of ancient
Greek at the time,
including attic,
the dialect of Athens as well as ionic.
These epic poems were written in homeric
Greek,
a literary form of the language based on
the ionic dialect of Greek with elements
of some other dialects during the
classical period of Greek history.
More texts of tremendous importance to
Western civilization were written in
ancient Greek,
including the works of Socrates,
Plato,
and Aristotle,
and many texts of foundational
importance in logic,
math and science.
Cornay Greek with the conquest of
Alexander the Great.
In the fourth century bce,
the Greek language became widespread in
a form known as Koine Greek Qa,
meaning common.
It was based mainly on the attic and
ionic dialects with some elements of
others as well,
and it served as a Lingua Franca
throughout the conquered regions.
It was spoken most widely in the eastern
Mediterranean region.
A large amount of important literature
was written in Koine Greek,
including the new testament and the
septuagint,
the Greek translation of the Old
Testament Koininia Greek remains the
Lingua Franca of the eastern
Mediterranean region during the Roman
Empire,
and became the official language of the
Byzantine Empire until the 15th century
medieval Greek medieval Greek,
also known as Byzantine Greek,
developed from Koine Greek during the
Byzantine Empire.
During this period,
the spoken language based on coin,
a Greek began to develop towards modern
Greek.
Wow.
Written Greek tended to be more
conservative and similar to ancient
Greek modern Greek.
The end of the Byzantine Empire marks
the beginning of the modern Greek period
during the modern Greek period,
two forms of Grieco rose.
The first was demotic or Zemo Tki,
which means by the people.
This is the modern spoken form of the
Greek language.
The second was a literary form of Greek
with features of both demotic Greek and
ancient Greek.
This resulted in a state of dye glossier
with the spoken language and the formal
written language being significantly
different until the adoption of demotic
as the official language of Greece in
1976 that form of demotic is referred to
as standard modern Greek.
There are several dialects of modern
Greek as well.
Northern dialect,
Ionian,
Peloponnesian dialects,
southern dialects is that Konijn all the
Athenian,
and there's also the Cypriot dialect
spoken on the island of Cyprus with one
exception,
the endangered saccone and dialect.
All forms of modern Greek developed from
Koine Greek.
Despite this long history and it's
different stages of development,
the Greek language has changed
relatively little compared to other
languages during the same timeframe.
My understanding is that speakers of
modern Greek can look at an ancient
Greek text and recognize a lot of
familiar vocabulary,
a lot of familiar words,
even if they can't make sense of the
sentence itself.
This relative lack of change in the
language is probably the result of
ancient Greeks continued influence on
written Greek throughout the centuries.
So what is Greek like?
Let's examine some of the features of
Greek,
specifically modern Greek syntax.
There's disagreement over whether Greeks
default word order is Svo or V,
s o,
but the most common word order is Svo.
Look at this sentence here
in the Smi Lama in Unica,
this sentence means we speak Greek.
Here's the subject,
the verb and the object.
But in Greek,
the subject Pronoun is not always
necessary.
Neelam aliens.
The subject pronouns isn't necessary
here because we know from the verb
conjugation that this is the first
person plural.
So if the subject Pronoun is typically
used when you want to draw attention to
it or make it the topic of the sentence,
despite Svo being the most common word
order in Greek,
the words can actually be arranged in
different ways.
Usually to put focus on one element of
the sentence.
Here's a sentence that means niece loves
Maria.
Oh,
young niece Maria.
This sentence here is Svo and notice
that the definite article comes before
proper names.
Maria [inaudible]
this time it's Oh v S
oh young is demaria of a pie.
This time it's s o.
V.
See Maria
[inaudible]
this time it's o s v.
These three word orders.
Here are all ways of drawing focus to
the object of the sentence.
It's possible to change the order of the
words like this because grammatical case
inflections tell us the nouns function
even if it's in a different location.
There are four grammatical cases in
Greek,
nominative,
genitive,
accusative,
and Vocativ.
Incentives is like these with proper
names.
The names themselves don't have case
inflections,
but the definite articles do notice that
the two definite articles or different,
we'll come back to that in a minute.
Let's look at another sentence and see
the nouns.
Case inflection.
This sentence means I lost my new
glasses word for word.
It's lost I,
which we know from the inflection,
the new glasses,
my this word,
which means glasses is an inflected form
of the neuter Noun,
which means glass.
It's the nominative,
accusative and Vocativ plural form.
Yes,
it can be all three of those.
Also,
the definite article is inflected to
agree with the now this is the nuture
nominative,
accusative plural form of the definite
article.
As you can see,
there are several other forms of the
definite article too.
Let's go back to an earlier sentence.
For a second.
This definite article here before young
niece is in the masculine singular
nominative form and this definite
article here before Maria is in the
feminine singular accusative form.
Even when the word order changed,
the definite article stayed the same.
Allowing us to know which person was the
subject,
the nominative case and which one was
the object,
the accusative case.
Also the adjective is inflected to agree
with the now this is the nuder
nominative,
accusative,
vocativ plural form.
Now let's change the noun in the
sentence and see what happens.
This means I lost my new dog this time.
The Noun is inflected to show the
masculine singular accusative form.
The definite article is also in the
masculine singular accusative form and
so as the adjective.
The main thing I want you to notice here
is that the now but also the words that
come together with the now like the
definite article and the adjective
change form to showcase,
but also gender and number verbs.
Greek verbs have two different stems,
two different forms.
One to show perfect mood,
which means an action is complete and
one to show imperfect mood,
which means an action is incomplete.
Then various affixes particles and
auxiliary verbs are added to these two
stems to show past tense and non past
tense.
Let's examine the meaning to help.
This is the perfect stem showing
completed action Wli thesis,
and this is the imperfect stem.
Now let's look at how to create some
verb tenses based on these stems.
Here's the present tense voice.
This means I am helping my friend and
this could also mean I helped my friend.
In a general sense,
the present tense form is based on the
imperfect stem because the action is not
complete yet it's happening.
Now,
here's the imperfect tense,
very suicidal.
This means I was helping my friend or I
used to help my friend.
Again,
this form is based on the imperfect stem
because the action was continuing at a
certain point in the past.
Now here's the simple past
[inaudible].
This means I helped my friend.
The simple past is based on the perfect
verb stem because the action is
complete.
Future
Savoy.
You see sort of feeling
this means I will help my friend.
The simple future tense is also based on
the perfect stem because it's an action
with a start and a finish.
It's not a continuing action and the
present perfect
cc [inaudible] Flores.
This means I have helped my friend many
times,
the present perfect.
It's also based on the perfect stem,
as you might've guessed from its name,
because the action has been done at some
point in the past.
Also notice the auxiliary verb,
which is the first person singular form
of the verb,
meaning to have.
Let's look at one final Greek sentence
and see what we discover
in this [inaudible].
The sentence means we fell in love and
got married.
Immediately.
Word for word it.
We fall in love,
past tense.
First person,
plural,
inflection and get married.
Past tense.
First person,
plural.
Immediately.
This verb,
it'll tell them it means to fall in
love.
This verb means to get married.
This ending is the first person,
plural,
past tense conjugation.
This piece here show us past tense and
this piece shows number and person.
These two verbs are not active verbs but
rather medio passive verbs.
You might see the word passive there and
think that these are passive verbs,
but medio passive verbs are not always
passive.
They might also be intransitive or
reflexive or reciprocal.
In this case,
they seem to be reciprocal,
meaning that both people are doing the
action to each other or with each other.
This ending here on the dictionary form
of the verb is a hint that it's a medial
passive verb.
One of the main things you may have
noticed about Greek is that it's a
highly inflected language with lots of
different word forms and lots of
different endings that can attach to
nouns and to verb stems and that might
seem kind of intimidating,
but there are lots of languages out
there that are much more inflected then
Greek,
so please don't be scared of that.
The story of the Greek language is a
very long and spectacular one and
there's so much to say about Greek that
we can't fit into this video,
but hopefully you were a little bit
inspired to learn more about Greek.
One of the oldest languages in the world
and a language that has influenced many
other languages and the very foundations
of Western civilization and thought,
okay,
the question of the day to native
speakers of Greek,
how well can you understand written
Greek from the past,
like Koine Greek and ancient Greek,
and to people who have studied Greek?
What did you find challenging and not so
challenging about Greek?
Be sure to follow length,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And as always,
I would like to say thank you to all of
my wonderful patrion supporters,
especially these people right here on
the screen for their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.